first up sometimes you gotta have it out
news program to news program
and recently john oliver gave us a
little shout out on last week tonight
from the man and the group of people who
took the form as far as it could be
taken
i can't love the john oliver show more
but keep your eyes on us guys because
we're coming for you
last week tonight shoots here at the cbs
broadcast center where we shoot our show
we've already staked our claim over your
domain in the building
that used to be your entrance before you
gave it up
are you coming back to the building
let's do that
i love the donald show i was watching it
when that happened i screamed out loud
in my living room
the fact that john oliver and his
amazing
team knows we exist rossi i can't be
more excited i mean
they really did advance the forum oh my
gosh they've changed the game completely
and
they're watching hi i'm like
uh they got great taste uh up next we
got a story about
nike now i don't know if you remembered
you but back in like 2019
they faced a little criticism for their
treatment of pregnant athletes that they
partner with
because some of them when they got
pregnant they like didn't renew their
contracts right
well they've taken positive steps to
change their pay policy
and to provide more protections to
athletic mothers and now
glamour reports they're paying tribute
to them now in their new maternity ad
and guess what we've got a clip what is
an athlete
someone who moves sounds like you
someone who gets it done no matter what
you do that yeah this is i think a great
example of a company
hearing the public and addressing it you
know and
having a baby is like the most
miraculous thing that your body can do
you know and so talk about athletic i'm
like to the founders of nike how do you
think you got here
yeah all right so congratulations for
waking up
yeah what she said that's great if
you're not a super elite athlete
but just what
[Applause]
um if you're not a super elite athlete
but just want to squeeze in a light
workout with a good playlist in your
ears
check this new feature out on spotify
popsugar reports that you can create a
custom
playlist inspired by your pet
that's right this is the new trend it's
super fun
easy to do you go to pets.buyspotify.com
and select your pet dog cat iguana
hamster bearded dragon
you know and you give some details on
your pet's attitude and personality
upload a photo and just like that you've
got a playlist to match
your pet's vibe yeah i did it i picked
for selena
and you go in and you talk about they
ask you questions about their
personality she's like
part chihuahua part hippopotamus she's
just like total slow-mo
and so i answered questions about her
personality and they put together a
playlist and it turns out selena is in
her feelings
because it's like um you're still the
one by shania twain
i want to do this i love this though
because i whenever i leave the house i
always
i leave music on for them meditation
music because i think
they're probably stressed out that i'm
not there they don't care
well maybe i should leave some music on
for them too
yeah i'm gonna leave on twisted sister
you